i wonder if the post-credits scene will
be cruella
we know someone with a lot of dalmatians
how many pregnant pause
smash
cruella de vil cruella de vil
if dizzy doesn't copyright us
somebody else will oh
it's all worth it for the run just
reached the whole video for that and
let's hope there's an actual song in the
trailer
just so it just feels like whatever it
doesn't matter anyway make it feel like
a foregone conclusion
trailer starring emma stone i
i am so curious to see how the hell this
movie's going to be handled
absolutely given the nature of this
character
what her motivations are character who
wants to
take dog skin them and turn them into
clothing i have no clue how you could
possibly make this a protagonist this is
just
a teaser supposed to be i'm on disney
plus if i'm not mistaken oh yeah it's
another fine film coming right to your
door yeah
let's see what's in store
from the very beginning i realized i saw
the world differently than everyone
else not a bad british accent
[Laughter]
sin city good laugh solid laugh
that it does cruella
okay dalmatians
[Laughter]
it's going to upset someone in that line
what the is there like a supernatural
element to this
i guess those bats yeah
oh that must be jasmine horace okay
cool hi yeah this looks cool
it's like a full-on villain origin story
hell yeah hell yeah
we live in a society we do live in a
society we live in a society
yeah when you when i come out can you
introduce me
as cruella i saw disney's joker trending
yeah i was like disney must mean cruella
and actually
after watching i thought it was just
because of the aesthetic choice of
cruella that i thought that was the case
but now that i'm watching this trailer
even the way the cinematography is done
and the editing style
the descent of someone into embracing
their own
madness yeah yeah it's very much
disney's joker right here
very curious to see what the actual tone
of this movie turns out to be because it
sure looks like it wants to take
at least cues from their approach to
protagonizing
a villain part of me is like who exactly
is this for
we're aiming to the adults who grew up
on this stuff a lot more than we're
aiming at the kids now which
is fine i mean this looked actually like
a lot of fun to me and i like
what emma stone's bringing to it uh it
looks like it's got a really great and
colorful cast emma thompson
always is fun in situations like these
you know it's bold
it's bold it can be bold it depends
we got to keep in mind this is a teaser
trailer this is the first trailer for
disney all right so i remember with
maleficent people were like oh man
they're really doing the dark thing
and then they're like not real i don't
know maybe they'll listen to the
criticism that had with maleficent i
don't know how you can
really turn this character into someone
who's sympathetic from my understanding
this movie is supposed to take place in
the 70s supposed to be about a fat like
the fashion designer days someone who's
kind of in the more
antagonist role of this movie is
actually the emma thompson character
she's someone who hires cruella in this
movie so i think this is her like story
from
estella to cruella right this is her
devil wears prada
exactly thompson's gonna be meryl streep
that's why i thought it was funny to
actually even see stanley tucci in this
trip yeah and in terms of capturing some
like dark
grittiness from the 1970s and the
turmoil from this
lady's life i buy it you know i i'm
actually really hoping
i'm really really hoping the movie
itself
this trailer is an accurate reflection
of it and it's not like
ah no she's a good character she's
somehow a hero i don't exactly know what
the hell was going on there
with the with the clothes with that just
some like magic
trick some fashion presentation thing or
was there something with like
bats at one point was this is this some
type of
symbolic theatrical setup stage thing
that she's done
to be like i am the devil yeah or is it
just like they're taking the world of
fashion like
you know that exists to a degree in
fashion especially high fashion like
here's something you might not ever wear
but it has this really cool feature
that's going to look amazing on a runway
or at a gala or something
so i'm talking about when the clouds
incinerate well yeah i i'm saying like
is that just
like a really whimsical extrapolation of
that because they make burn away paper
and they make stuff that can burn but
not burn the layer underneath
or whatever but then at the same time it
does look like a pretty
magical effect i'm curious because that
is a movie the original ones anyway are
pretty grounded other than the talking
animals there is a real
joker vibe especially when you slow down
this trailer with the cruella
and the crowd surrounding her people
embracing their darkness and then
that's gonna lead the revolution did you
even see moments where like the makeup
is very much like like i get on cruella
but everyone has kind of this like clown
makeup aesthetic to it
the color palette right yeah i hope that
this movie commits
to this level of darkness i just have a
hard time believing it actually will
that it might it'll probably just be
some like whimsical thing i bet i think
those other two men that you see here
sometimes within this trailer
has got to be horus and jasper from the
uh original animated movie yeah you got
to give those guys an origin man
you got to show how they met yeah that's
what i always wanted when i saw 101
dalmatians definitely
you see the uh some dalmatians in here
too that's what i mean like is that
going to be included in this movie yeah
she's gonna have like a longer horrible
connection to this breed of dog than we
thought
well this director i think can pull it
off he's done some disney movies that
are fine but disney likes them the
finest hours a million dollar arm he's
also done
movies with weird psychological studies
of people
like lars and the real girl and i tonya
i got more of those vibes i tonya and
lars and the real girl that like
weird psychological yeah
very much captured and depicted through
our main character's descent
and their perspective yes and i love the
colors in it i love the composition
of the shots it does look like very high
fashion like and
even though it's in the 70s like it has
this weird timeless quality because
everything is like set in these super
upscale and old buildings and things
yeah and emma stone does look great
and i love all the different changes and
outfits we'll see if it ends up any good
guys we'll see if it ends up any good
what do you think of this cruella
trailer are you excited for it to
pleasantly surprise you if it is
anything like the trailer the movie
itself then i'm all for it
subscribe click the notification bell
hit that like button last but not least
sarah campbell beautiful woman all the
way from
toronto she's starting to go a little
bit crazy herself because of the state
of the world that we live in
she had concert tickets to many things
recently she was gonna see
goo goo dolls who had that one song she
was gonna see boston calling
and she was most excited to go see foo
fighters
and my favorite band and you did ask me
who are some of my favorite bands is my
favorite band red hot chili peppers
so damn your year sucks yeah wow what'd
you miss out on a lot
it's time to find some animals and turn
them into firsts sarah
that's something you can do on your own
to pass the time if i can influence you
to do
such a thing then that's on your
upbringing that's not on me man like you
should have been listening
to i don't know anything we tell you
like you've watched enough psychological
thrillers to know that that's that's not
my fault maybe
stop watching making a joke i mean i
love you sarah thank you sir